[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich traue ich strahle die sich auf gute
energie beim schönheits ausstrahlung
sexy food ich bin ich auch noch der tod
nicht so sein wie ich es mir leid ist
gibt's noch eine ja leute haben herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video haben hier
sitzbereich dem titel eingebildet und
zwar immer wieder eine challenge sandra
hört musik und ich musste sagen und
sander muss danach wieder geben was ich
gesagt habe und dann höre ich musik oder
wir fangen mit dem ersten satz den ich
habe dann die polizei
ich habe jetzt im netz ist los geht
alle fische können schwimmen alle fische
können spüren alles geschickt werden
alle fische
nein alles bestimmen können schwimmen
alle frische grün bewusst ja alle fische
können schwimmen früchte können alle
richtig können schwimmen alle fische
können keine küche alle alle fische
können schwimmen alle fische können
nein alle tische können schwimmen also
sind alle fische können können stimmen
alle drei sehen können können schwimmen
können können können können schwimmen
schwimmen ja wettringer oder direkt er
wisse dass er direkt erraten
sandra ist cool aber du nicht sandra
[Applaus]
alaska dann alles klar sagen wir den
sack von vorne jetzt einfach feld
fordert das kommt aber du nicht langsam
macht dann heißt cool aber du nicht
wertvoller wenn alle nein-sager apfel
salat april/mai carola alaska 2000 jahre
später alles klar ist cool sagt mal das
erste wort sammlern also komplett sauber
eigentlich heißt die fresse kinder
[Musik]
altenheimen dranhalten video sein
ich gehe jetzt mal aus sandra ist cool
aber so die duh nicht weil er absolut
gar nichts viele menschen haben glück
aber einige menschen haben auch pech ach
ja wie viele menschen haben glück aber
einige menschen haben ob nicht erstes
wort bitte viele viele du musst weiter
fort viele viele viele viele mehr viele
viele viele viele viele viele menschen
[Musik]
helfen könnten menschen helfen menschen
stellen menschen grenzen mehr diesen
menschen viele menschen haben ihr glück
[Musik]
glück aber alle haben aber arbeit aber
am berg der aber naja aber weißt aber
was aber das wird so aber
viele menschen nach dem kopf aber einige
richtig einige einige einige einige
angst sind einige einigen
was ist eine art einige mit dem satz ja
eigentlich viele menschen haben glück
aber einige menschen haben auch kein
glück ich weiß dass ich gar nicht der
satz aber sand so lange dafür gebraucht
so wie diese wörter herauszufinden dass
ich dieses anscheinend selbst schon
wieder vergessen habe ja gut egal wir
machen jetzt weiter mit der nächsten
runde langsamer als nico
wie fliegen fliegen fliegen
sika fliegen die kiezkicker wir hier
immer von ff7 sieht war lief normal egal
sind sind cool
das war's ja ok
er hat heute an der stelle würden sei
noch nicht das heutige video jetzt auch
beenden es hat überhaupt nicht
funktioniert hat wie die idee weil sie
diese kopfhörer hier gefunden hat
vielleicht war so ein reden ohne ton und
er redete mit dem raster warum
hierzu werden wir jetzt auf elton bitte
schreibt um die kommentare das ich
glaube ich verabschiede mich jetzt seht
ihr in kroko wie anderes video gucken
können
[Musik]
die meisten wahrscheinlich so ist alles
gut und ich werde davon sagte das
anregen
[Musik]